what if you woke up to an unexpected
Internet breakdown would you be able to
survive without checking facebook for
new postings first thing in the morning
with no Google Maps to find your way in
a strange city with a credit card unable
to pay for lunch if you're watching this
video it means the internet is still
going but what if someone or something
shut it down this is what if and here's
what would happen if the internet
stopped working
you could argue this kind of digital
detox would be beneficial we'd take our
eyes off our screens and strike up
real-life conversations with each other
we've discovered that our smartphones
can actually make phone calls we bring
back fax machines and start making notes
by hand
well maybe not fax machines and hey we'd
still have TV to entertain us the world
would not fall apart
in fact with almost 4 billion people
having no access to the Internet
worldwide
half of humanity wouldn't notice a
difference in the short term but not you
mighty internet user you would notice
right away if the internet suddenly
flatlined social media users would start
calling each other on the phone
overloading the working
telecommunication systems unless cell
phone towers and telephone lines were
also shut down then you'd go back to
writing letters and sending them via
post forget about Wireless file
transfers with no Wi-Fi you'd have to
use a physical cable to connect to
computers or a CD remember this now
think about the economy with financial
data generally stored on a server
banking services largely depend on the
Internet
each transfers would be impossible your
credit card and debit card would become
a useless piece of plastic and what
about all those bitcoins you worked so
hard to mine
well you know the answer on top of that
large companies like Google Facebook and
Amazon would go out of business
losing their combined revenue of almost
four hundred and forty billion dollars
with Google itself having 80,000
full-time staff hundreds of thousands of
people would be left unemployed even
companies that only rely on the Internet
as a means of advertising would be
affected developed countries would lose
entire industries and face economic
crisis what about those countries with
just a small internet presence they
would be affected too as international
trade is dependent on the internet so is
the world's transit with no internet
access between airports planes ships
trains and commercial trucking we'd go
back to tracking goods on paper this
would raise the market value on
transported products as it would be more
complicated to deliver goods to stores
at least you could still travel however
you won't have Instagram to share your
travel selfies anymore wonder if the
internet shutdown is even possible well
not on a worldwide level some countries
have actually introduced a kill switch
to intentionally shut down the internet
and telephone communications but killing
the whole internet is harder than just
cutting off a couple submarine cables
the Internet is a global network of many
other computer networks it doesn't
depend on a single machine even if one
part of it went offline others would
remain functional so don't worry you'll
still be able to order pizza for dinner
tonight
[Music]